we have this story from timcast.com
Mitch McConnell abruptly stops speaking
freezes during press conference the
Senate minority leader was escorted of
the room by Senator John Barraza of
Wyoming let me play this video for you
it is saddening and I would describe it
as a seizure potentially a stroke here
we go
dessert oh sorry I gotta turn the audio
on bring it up no I just got to press
the audio there fortunately he doesn't
speak for 30 years in cooperation
and a string of uh
that's it that's the video he says
cooperation a string of and then just
freezes it's I went to I went to a um a
fundraiser a long time ago political
fundraiser for seizure awareness
and this guy who suffered grand mal
seizures
uh was explaining how often he'll be in
public meetings or at work
and uh he'll freeze exactly like Mitch
McConnell did and people will laugh at
him
and he could he could die and he was
like Awareness on what seizures look
like is extremely important because of
Hollywood everyone thinks you fall to
the ground and start spazzing out
some people said I think it's like an
absent or absence seizure absent seizure
where you just freeze and lock up and a
lot of people were tweeting that this is
maybe what it was apparently he said
that he got light-headed and he was fine
and then went on to have like a normal
meeting afterwards or whatever but I
think what we're seeing here is
you know we talked a whole lot about
aliens in law and morality
our political leaders
they keep winning no matter what no
matter what because our culture is dead
because this country will just walk into
a booth and rubber stamp D or R without
a thought because it is a dead culture
so against them so they vote for Pelosi
they vote for Mitch McConnell they vote
for people who should have retired 30
years ago and I don't see it changing
unless there's a hard fall you think it
was TV that deadened culture
no no I think it's uh it's it's like
it's the straw side generational uh
Theory so I I would argue what you're
describing there's a lot of Truth to
what you're saying Tim and I think that
it is ultimately a spiritual sickness
that we are facing because we have lost
the plot like what is the point of human
existence is it to just take is it to
just you know become more powerful or
more perfect like what's the point of
human existence is it to love and to
serve and ultimately For Eternity for
God or is it to take and that difference
I think if people are kind of
wishy-washy on that they don't know what
their purpose is then we don't really
care enough and then we just you know
maybe stamp what you're saying D or R or
whatever it is we're going in and we're
not really caring enough to really fight
but I do think a lot of people are
fighting for the country right now and
they care and they're raising young
families I know my family we're raising
a young family we're passionate we care
about the future we think there is a
future and enough of those people if
enough of us do that we can change it
it's going to be painful and hard at
points but I think we can change the
country and make it better so I don't
think it's hopeless Dianne Feinstein
remember she gets she goes she's out in
the for what was it a couple months or
something how long was she out for and
then she's like I was here the whole
time
I absolutely despise these people
Mitch McConnell we can talk about his
politics all day and night I'll tell you
oh I don't like he does this and like he
does that but there is nothing that that
gives me more disdain for this man than
this medical episode I have no sympathy
no empathy for his freeze up for his
stroke or seizure because he is gripping
on to the the to the leadership position
that a younger person needs to have to
help this country and he's incapable of
doing it but it's not just him it is it
is it is a problem in this country and
all of Congress where they're all it's
just and look at who is running for
president we're gonna have Biden versus
Trump I think Trump's better than Biden
but even Trump is older it was one of
the big big reasons we were saying
DeSantis is probably better is that he's
a lot younger unfortunately I don't
think the Santa is going to be able to
pull it off because he can't seem to get
a hold of his campaign well here these
people need to leave you thin and of
itself I think is not the key but to
your point I think you know if you're
very to the point of having strokes and
you need medical leave you should take
care of your health and not be trying to
lead the country in this case but I
think think it's not just youth it's
wisdom and I think there's a crisis of
wisdom and that's where even young
leaders are terrible so it's not like
they just because you're young you're
better if you're young you could be even
more foolish McConnell doesn't seem to
have any real wisdom about him either
that could be true I will not argue with
that I mean and I think he he has done
some good things in his career but I do
think I agree with you we need we need
more we need fresh not just fresh
leadership we need good good leadership
calcified I don't know if it's calcified
pineal gland but we less aspartame in
people's diets less high fructose corn
syrup yeah corroding the neural network
someone points out on Twitter any job in
this country you are 81 years old and
suffer a seizure they would say look
it's it's it's it's time you go home
right this is not the job for you in
fact can he even be driving anymore I'm
not trying to rag on older people but
there is a point at which you are too
young for a job and too old for a job
we're not going to put 12 year olds in
the coal mines we should be putting 81
year olds in Congress do you think we
have should do age limits now
it is a tough question because of the
rate of Technology it should be more
about capability I agree with that I
think if you're if you're struggling
with serious medical conditions just
like as you described from work you
could take a leaf so would it be
Congress that votes to have the other
Congressman removed if there's a medical
thing I I I would love I would love it
right now if uh Congress uh voted to uh
the Senate voted to remove Mitch
McConnell it's almost imperative
you know we're missing a Kentucky
representative right now Feinstein
should we should be out and McConnell
should be out and It's Tricky when
they've been democratically elected
right that is that is straight back to
what you were talking about earlier Tim
you know if we got into a system where
we get to just out people because we
consider them physically unfit but they
were democratically elected you know it
gets into no it's interesting we remove
people from Congress all the time all
right not all the time it's happened a
couple times you vote to send someone
home uh
I I wonder if the vague ramaswamy he has
he had a couple proposals one publicly
he said there should be a Civics test in
order to vote I'm not a fan of that I
don't think that makes sense what I
really like is you have to sign up for
the selective service if you want to
vote if you sign up for the Selective
Service it you get a voter ID and if you
have that you're allowed to vote and so
I think that will solve a great deal of
of our problems overnight Vivek actually
clarified on the show last week he
thinks when you turn 18 you don't have
voting register 25 unless you pass a
Civics test or do six months of
community service or military service so
it's either or
do you do I disagree so you don't like
this Civics test uh I'm not a big fan of
it I don't think I don't think it
necessarily solves the problem
see the thing is about signing up for
the selective Services you're basically
saying I'm willing to die for this
country and guess what it's a very
simple sign on the dotted line that no
Democrat would be able to convince a
run-of-the-mill urban liberal to sign
but every conservative would be like I
love this country
put my name down however a lot of people
are going to say I wouldn't sign up for
that this country is corrupt no no if
the voting base is just comprised of
people who have pledged their lives to
this country you are not going to have
these corrupt people because they can't
get elected yeah but you know crazy
president was like oh now all you guys
all you voters signed up for the
Selective Service we're going to war
because they vote because as only those
people who get to vote so when the
president comes in and says Ah Mission
initiating the draft it's those people
who say recall yeah any impeachment
anything that that like shrinks the
number of of ignorant votes uh I'm for
so limit voting like in any way possible
in my opinion I don't think that uh that
it requires service
um I do get where you're coming from I I
understand the uh the the the idea that
you have to have something on the line I
personally think that maybe owning a
business or owning Pro like something
like that because you can start a
business on with a cell phone so like if
you actually start a business and you
have some kind of skin in the game and
the barrier for entry is real low for
that and again I'm not saying it's
perfect but I'm I'm I just don't think
that that you have to go through you
know serving the country uh but you
don't should be signing up the selective
service does not mean you're going to do
any service oh okay so you're oh yeah
all right it means that if the United
States is invaded you you've pledged
your life to defend it yeah now a lot of
people argue that but the draft in World
War one two in the Korean war in Vietnam
I'm like no no listen my point is this
there's corruption right now it may just
be an idealistic perfect system but
imagine if the only people who could
vote meaning there could not be a
foreign invasion of Syria everybody who
had to go fight it were the people who
were voting they'd be like I'm not gonna
go do that so I'm voting against these
people everyone else who sits in their
Ivory Tower sipping tea being like we
should go to war for oil wouldn't have a
vote and and if they wanted to go they'd
vote and you know what they're making a
point where let's say you've got a 350
million people in this country only 175
actually choose to sign up for Selective
Service to vote and this is split vote
and 100 million say we want to go to war
for this reason and 75 say you don't but
that's the point of saying I pledge to
this system it's not always going to be
about what you want but you know
everyone else voting for it has pledged
the same thing as you and we don't even
have everyone voting though who I think
is well equipped to vote so this is
but I disagree with that entirely I
think there's a lot of people that don't
vote that I think should vote is what
I'm saying really yeah especially like
in the pro-life space and in the space
where people have values they love the
country they love what we were founded
on they believe in the future for the
country often yes many are active and
politically involved but the thing is a
lot of people who are doing that are
busy running their businesses and
raising their families and so maybe
they're not doing every election you
know maybe they're not as involved as
they need to be so we encourage more
Civic engagement right look look and
Mitch McConnell his biggest issue is not
I mean I hope he's well you know but I
think his biggest issue is a failure to
lead on fundamental human rights and the
Republican party has made some strides
because it's in our platform that life
begins at fertilization and that
abortion should not be permitted and
that legal protection is deserved by All
pre-born Humans Mitch McConnell has not
LED like that he's been squishy you're
the fastest way to get that is
exactly what I just said I I went uh
when I worked for these non-profits 15
some odd years ago they said anybody
here want to go see Death Cab for Cutie
live and I was like that's like my
favorite band I would love to go see
them live and they're like here's your
vinyl all access pass here's your stack
of voter registration forms you're gonna
walk around and register people register
people to vote but it gets you backstage
access and I was like yes and I walked
around back you want to vote you want to
vote I did not know their political
affiliation but come on it's Chicago
they're all Democrats what if I walked
up to them and said hey do you want to
vote and they went sure I'll sign up
just sign that you'll you want to join
the draft and fight in the military no
way thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time